[Musique]
merci Catherine Jumin de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de Paris membre
du groupe les républicains vous présidez
désormais le groupe d'opposition au
conseil de Paris on va bien sûr
longuement revenir sur ce qui se passe
là-bas mais d'abord l'actualité on l'a
vu dans le journal c'est donc Gabriel
Atal qui a dévoilé hier son gouvernement
au complet sans aucun nouveau débauchage
à l'air vous êtes soulagé soulagé on
constate moi ce que je constate surtout
c'est que je dirais tout ça pour ça on a
mis le Premier ministre et le président
de la République parce qu'on sait qu'il
est très lié ont mis beaucoup de temps
pour nous présenter une équipe avec
beaucoup de sortants d'ailleurs des
inconnus on a pu résoudre le
problème éducation nationale semble-t-il
et puis satisfaire monsieur Berrou euh
bon voilà après qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
de ce ministes c'est ça la grande
question le président dirige la France
d'une façon très verticale euh il nomme
des ministres on voit il met beaucoup de
temps pour les nommer pourtant il y a
aucune surprise après qu'est-ce qu'il en
fera parfois on se demande s'il a pas
plutôt envie d'avoir des délégués
interministériels ça serait plus
pratique et qu' puissent tout faire donc
voilà moi j'attends Gabriel Atal il dit
qu'il a un gouvernement de combat pour
vous c'est pas un gouvernement de combat
à voir je vais pas porter de jugement
alors que pour certains ministres je
nouveaux ministres je ne les connais
absolument pas à voir mais euh je vois
le mode de fonctionnement du président
de la République et je me dis que le
premier ministre va avoir quand même
beaucoup de difficultés on a beaucoup
parlé de la représentation territoriale
d'un gouvernement trop parisien euh il y
a aussi également une représentation
parlementaire il y a 19 députés il y a
un seul sénateur et encore c'est
Sébastien Lecornu qui n'a jamais siégé
ici au Sénat est-ce que vous le
regrettez alors en revanche je suis ravi
que Sébastien lecorneu reste avec ce
portefeuille parce que c'est un très bon
ministre des Armées euh donc ça c'est
une première chose après c'est vrai il
n'y a pas de sénateur le Sénat
représente les territoires on nous avait
dit que qu'il y aurait un rééquilibrage
entre les parlementaires qui
parlementaires qui deviendrai ministrre
ça pas été le cas don vous regrettez que
aucun sénateur n'est rejoint le
gouvernement oui alors oui don Tacte je
cherchais pas spécialement ce que ça
soit DLR loin de là mais en revanche oui
dont acte le Sénat compte et la deuxème
chambre donc oui on est c'est quand même
la preuve que la majorité sénatoriale a
sur resté unie on parlait de débochage
de sénateurs alert de sénateur centré un
c'est la pre de l'uné maû je pense que
c'est surtout la preuve que personne
n'est dupe et que le dépuchage politique
personne n'en veut ça peut satisfaire
des ambitions personnelles mais que
c'est pas efficace après les accords de
parti les accords de gouvernement c'est
autre chose mais le débauchage personnel
ça sert à rien mais est-ce que vous
craignez que ce soit aussi le signe
qu'il soit peu conu peu pardon tenu
compte des territoires finalement oui
mais encore une fois je reviens à ce que
je disais début de propos c'est que j'ai
un peu peur que tout soit fait d'une
façon très très verticale depuis
l'Élysée et que en effet les territoires
ne soit pas associé Amélie ou casterra a
donc été sortie du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale remplacé par
Nicole Boubé c'est une bonne chose pour
vous je pense que le gouvernement avait
un problème que depuis un mois elle
avait été maladroite et qu'on voyait
bien que ça ne fonctionnait plus
notamment avec les syndicats il aussi un
problème d'image donc il apparaî c'est
évident que elle pouvait ement continuer
ce travail après Nicole Boubet c'est une
femme de gauche qui donc je l'imagine
sera parlé au au syndicat c'est une
femme respectueuse avoir c'est un vaste
travail parce que c'est un très gros
chantier pour notre pays et très
important on a entendu François berou
ces dernières heures très critiqu envers
la ligne politique du gouvernement
envers Emmanuel Macron Gabriel hatal
pourtant quatre ministres du MoDem reste
dans ce gouvernement est-ce que vous
savez où se situe le modem aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas et quand vous vous dites
pourtant qure ministr moi je me dis je
dis plutôt que c'est grâce à sa grosse
colère qu'il a quatre ministres c'est
pas parce il en avait déjà 4 avant oui
mais justement donc après c'est un peu
je t'aime moins non plus avec le
président de la République François
berou on a un peu de mal à comprendre
ses relations et d'ailleurs apparemment
ses amis aussi ils ont tous dit qu'ils
étaient plus ou moins surpris par son
attitude donc et le modemme est encore
dans la majorité pour vous aujourd'hui
d'après ce que François berud a dit oui
on va continuer à parler de ce
remanimement ça fait aussi l'actualité
dans nos régions on va aller à
Strasbourg on retrouve Frédéric vezard
bonjour Frédéric merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédacteur en chef des
Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace et du
journal L'Alsace remaniment évidemment
qui était scruté de près comme dans
toutes les régions parce que vous avez
envie de savoir si avait des ministres
alsaciens qu'en est-il et bien il n'y en
a plus nous avions un ministre délégué
Olivier BCH qui qui n pas conservé son
son
portefeuille alors on avait envie de
savoir oui parce parce que vous savez il
y a c'est le général de Gaulle qui avait
posé ça en principe au moment de la
fondation de la 5è République il faut
toujours un ministre alsacien dans un
gouvernement euh pour la première fois
depuis longtemps il n'y en a
plus Carole Grandjean qui était
également la la seule lurine présente
dans le gouvernement également parti
donc on a on a le sentiment ici dans
l'est effectivement qu'on est un petit
peu un petit peu oublié d'une manière
générale et et c'est aussi la la
question que j'ai envie de poser à
madame la sénatrice on a le sentiment
ici d'avoir un gouvernement qui est très
effectivement très parisien très
resserré qui peu à peu se replier un peu
un peu sur lui-même alors un
gouvernement de combat sans doute un
gouvernement très politique mais avec un
risque je dira de fracture effectivement
avec avec les région et sans le coup de
gueule de François berou effectivement
on peut se demander si si cette rupture
aurait pas été un peu plus importante et
la question en fait que j'ai envie de
poser c'est est-ce que c'est pas
finalement un choix politique un peu
dangereux aujourd'hui de mettre en scène
cette cette opposition entre entre la
capitale et les régions
oui c'est cas bien sûr bonjour oui vous
avez raison de toute façon je pense
qu'aujourd'hui notre pays a besoin de
décentralisation d'aller au plus près
des territoires d'aller au plus près des
Français donc évidemment les
représentants et notamment les ministres
qui sont censé aussi comme vous le dites
avoir une appartenance territoriale
forcément parce que ils font de la
politique
ils sont issus d'un territoire
permettent de représenter ces
territoires c'est vrai et vous le dites
je le dis d'autant plus à l'aise que je
suis moi-même sénatrice parisienne il y
a une concentration de Franciliens et de
Parisiens dans ce gouvernement et je
pense qu'en effet c'est pas forcément
une bonne idée et que il faut prendre en
compte la réalité des territoires et que
les ministres franciliens parisiens
connaissent forcément moins les
territoires euh que que que les autres
donc oui moi je je pense que que c'est
dommage mais ça c'est une question qu'il
faudrait poser au président de la
République et au Premier ministre on va
revenir sur cette question de la
décentralisation parce qu'il en a été
question hier au Sénat mais d'abord
Frédéric euh on revient avec vous
puisqu'on va parler d'un sujet
d'inquiétude qui est développé
aujourd'hui dans les pages de vos
journaux c'est la pollution de l'eau
potable oui on a on a travaillé euh on a
travaillé sur ce sujet parce qu'on on a
euh à à Strasbourg en particulier des
laboratoires qui qui travaillent
là-dessus et en fait on on a fait un
sujet vous savez on parle souvent de la
pollution des pesticides de tout ce qui
est lié à la pollution agricole et en
fait on s'aperçoit à travers ces
recherches et l'article qu'on publé
aujourd'hui qu'il y a aussi une une part
de pollution qui est liée à notre
consommation de médicaments mais aussi
de vêtements par exemple des vêtements
importés euh qui contiennent parfois
justement des pesticides des éléments
polluant qui se retrouvent dans l'eau
des machines à laver et qui vont venir
polluer l'eau voilà c'est ce qu'on
appelle les les microlluants c'est c'est
moins visible que la que la pollution
que la pollution agricole mais ça
présente des risques euh réels pour la
pour la santé voilà donc il y a
effectivement des des labos ici en
Alsace qui qui travaillent là-dessus
mais c'est c'est quelque chose qu' va
falloir prendre en compte et qui doit
nous amener à nous interroger sur notre
consommation euh de médicaments de
vêtements voilà c'est c'est un sujet je
trouve intéressant et et qui permet
aussi de de de montrer que on est tous
un peu un peu responsable par rapport à
C à cette question de la pollution de
l'eau voilà on pointe souvent du doigt
les agriculteurs il n'y a pas
queux vous avez tout à fait raison et je
pense que c'est un un sujet qui va
devenir de plus en plus important
parallèlement il y a quand même une
prise de conscience je crois aujourd'hui
générale par rapport à ces sujets mais
ça interroge sur notre mode de vie
comment on fonctionne en effet et c'est
une question qui qui interroge toutes
nos habitudes dans tout ce qu'on fait
dans une journée en effet on
peut participer à cette pollution donc
il faut avoir cette prise de conscience
et puis évidemment travailler comme vous
le faites avec la recherche sur des
solutions merci Frédéric vezard merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
on regarde vos de unes la Une des
Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace l'éducation
change demain plus de ministres
alsaciens et puis la Une du journal
L'Alsace l'Alsace lutte contre les
micropolluants merci beaucoup merci
Frédéric vezard d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin on va parler je le disais de
décentralisation puisqu'il en a été
question hier au Sénat Gabriel hatal qui
a promis une nouvelle loi
décentralisation d'ici la fin de l'année
une noix qui s'inspirera de la mission
conduite par Eric W erict justement qui
était auditionné hier par les sénateurs
on voit ça avec Quentin
[Musique]
calm bonjour Quentin bonjouran bonjour
Catherine dumin bonjour et Quentin éic
vert était donc reçu hier par la
Délégation aux collectivités
territoriales du Sénat l'occasion de
faire le point sur la mission que lui a
confié le chef de l'État
effectivementian depuis l'automne
dernier l'ancien ministre sarkoziist
estché d'une mission sur la
décentralisation dans sa lettre de
mission on daté du 3 novembre dernier il
est chargé par le Président de la
République de plusieurs missions dont la
simplification de l'organisation
territorial la clarification des
compétences ou encore la simplification
des normes c'est dans cette lettre
effectivement qui lui a été envoyé donc
Eric vert était reçu hier au Sénat on
peut le dire à mi-chemin de sa mission
puisqu'elle doit se terminer par la
remise d'un rapport en mai et donc à la
clé un projet de loi voire même
plusieurs à sous-entendu Eric vert hier
en audition je suis en cours de travail
a dit hier le député ce n'est pas
l'heure des annonces mais parmi les
pistes sur lesquelles il travaille il y
a bien l'idée de retrouver un lien
direct entre le contribuable et le
citoyen écouter le chargé de mission
nous pensons qu'il faut utiliser la
fiscalité donc nationale la fiscalité
qui existe euh donc cette fiscalité
nationale on est en train de la regarder
de façon évidemment très proche pour
essayer de regarder quelle fiscalité
nationale pourrait être utilisée à quel
euh sur quel strate de de collectivité
locale ayant un lien avec une disons les
charges prépondérantes ou ou majoritaire
de cette même collectivité pas d'impôt
nouveau donc pour remplacer la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation ou
cette suppression de la CVAE vous savez
cette taxe locale sur les entreprises
Catherine Duma un conseil à Eric vert à
3 mois de la remise de ce rapport
qu'est-ce que vous attendez vous de
l'ancien ministre sarkozist alors je
sais pas si je vais donner des conseils
Eric Wort que je connais d'autre part
très bien et que j'apprécie beaucoup euh
ceci dit c'est très bien que le
Président de la République confie une
mission avec VTE sur la
décentralisation en effet je pense queon
a accumulé des strates qu'il faut
absolument remettre un peu d'ordre dans
tout ceci et j'espère qu'il y arrivera
fera des propositions intéressantes mais
le vrai sujet aussi c'est euh comment
après on va utiliser tous ces échelons
et on revient au propos de toute notre
conversation de ce matin c'est ne ne ne
recentralisons pas au niveau de l'État
si on travaille sur la décentralisation
très bien mais alors profitons-en à ce
moment là pour donner du pouvoirs aux
élus utilisons mieux le Sénat également
qui représente les collectivités locales
et on n' pas franchement l'impression
que le Président de la République ait
beaucoup envie de travailler avec nous
et et aussi vous vous vous mettez en
doute ces ces conviction ces convictions
mare de décentralisation c'est pas un
président décentralisateur vous le
croyez pas du tout pas du tout pour
l'instant il nous a montré beaucoup de
verticalité et le Sénat on est le
meilleur exemple donc je crois que ça a
été dit le Sénat souhaite travailler sur
ces sujets mais il faut l'utiliser
beaucoup plus puisqu'il est là pour
représenter ses collectivités d'ailleurs
nous travaillons aussi dans le cadre de
cette mission et de ces sujets sur un
statut de l'élu local il y a une
proposition de loi qui sera portée par
les présidents retaillot et Marseille
sur ce sujet et qui dit statut de l'élu
local évidemment on aborde tous ces
sujets parmi les autres idées orien qui
reviennent il y a celle du du conseiller
territorial idée de Nicolas Sarkozi
lancé en 2010 mais jamais appliqué une
fusion des conseillers départementaux et
régionaux est-ce que c'est toujours
pertinent alors Eric vert en plus l'a
rappelé les régions ont été agrandies
donc maintenant on a des très grandes
régions et il y a eu aussi un
redécoupage des des cantons donc il dit
la solution de 2010 ne pourrait pas être
décalquée en 2024 vous qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez oui je pense qu' qu'il a
raison à l'époque c'est vrai que Nicolas
Sarkozi avait un un bon schéma bon ça
c'est pas fait euh aujourd'hui en effet
on a ces régions gigantesques ça c'est
un vrai sujet on
va vraiment ça un sujet on va en parler
très bientôt donc on en parlait
notamment avec le grand test et l'Alsace
l'Alsace qui véité pour être
indépendante exactement donc peut-être
que cette mission va justement nous
donner l'occasion de de clarifier mais
je pense qu'en effet on peut pas revenir
à la solution qu'avait proposé Nicolas
Sarkozi donc il faut en trouver une
autre moi j'attends de voir ce qu'
quiorte va nous nous proposer il sera
notamment aussi question dans cette
mission du mode de scrutin pour Paris
Lyon-Marseille qu'Emmanuel Macron veut
revoir il veut que les maires de Paris
lion-marseille soient élu au suffrage
Universal direct et non plus via les
maires d'arrondissement comme
actuellement vous vous soutenez vous
soutiendrez ce ce changement du mode de
scrutin c'est un sujet qui me préoccupe
particulièrement d'autant plus que j'ai
pris nouvelle fonction en assurant la
présidence du groupe changé Paris au
Conseil de Paris qui évidemment voilà
nous sommes concernés et c'est le
premier chantier que je vais lancer
d'ailleurs avec M élus ils sont très
demandeurs donc on va travailler là on
finit le Conseil de Paris ce soir dès
lundi on va se mettre à travailler sur
ce chantier ça veut dire la fin des
arrondissements ah je sais pas on va
voir nous on le souhaite pas pareil on
parle de décentralisation ou de
reconcentration là pour le coup la fin
des arrondissements on reconcentre tout
au niveau de du maire de Paris oui mais
comment est-ce qu'on élit son maire au
surrage dire a plus de mer
d'arrondissement c'est toute la
difficulté en effet et nous nous sommes
évidemment pour le mainti des
arrondissements qui sont les plus
proches mais ça veut dire qu'il y a quoi
il y a deux bulletins de vote il y a un
vous choisissez votre maire
d'arrondissement de vous choisissez le
maire de Paris quand vous allez V
envager moi j'attends encore une fois de
voir ce que le gouvernement et suite à
Laé mission ver notamment va nous
proposer nous nous travaillons pour
avoir nos propres
proposition ça passera par des échanges
et après évidemment par la loi et à
savoir que si Marseille et Lyon aussi
auront les mêmes envies et les mêmes
besoins donc tout ceci est très
compliqué mais on ne peut pas aller sur
la disparition des arrondissements c'est
le contraire de ce que veulent les
Parisiens merci Quentin tout à l'heure
merciian oui je reviens dans le club on
analysera précisément les équilibres
politiques notamment du reménement
d'hier vous avez beaucoup compté ce
matin on
verra ai de V décomes ce sera su dans le
club à tout à l'heure Quentin on va
parler du Conseil de Paris vous le
disiez il a eu lieu cette semaine et
vous avez pris la présidence du groupe
d'opposition changé Paris depuis la
nomination de Rachid hadti et c'est la
première fois que Rachid hadti revenit
au Conseil de Paris depuis qu'elle a été
nommée ministre de la Culture comment ça
s'est passé mardi lors de son retour au
sein de votre groupe et ben très bien
Rachida et fait partie de notre groupe
bien entendu c'est une membre importante
de notre groupe elle est maintenant
ministre de la Culture ce qui est
important aussi pour Paris elle est
revenue participer à nos travaux
intervenir d'ailleurs sur le sujet de la
piétonisation de l'espace Trocadero
tourffel lienna qui est un vrai sujet
qui nous tient à cœur mais on veut que
ça se passe bien donc elle elle a fait
part de ses propositions ça s'est très
bien passé vous êtes senti trahi par sa
nomination son choix de rejoindre le
gouver non pas du tout faut pas employer
de de grands mots pas du tout trahi il y
a eu un effet de sidération j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire de surprise parce
que c'était une réelle surprise donc
forcément ben vous avez pas prévenu vous
avez pas consulté non pas du tout ça
personne n'est d'ailleurs bon je pense
que dans ce genre de
situation les choses se font très
discrètement et ça peut se comprendre on
éétait pas du tout ni prévenu ni
consulté donc on l'a pris on était
surpris mais après qu'est-ce qu'il a
fallu faire s'organiser pour assurer la
continuité de nos travaux c'est ce qu'on
a fait franchement depuis 3 jours passés
maintenant tout se passe bien c'est
compatible d'être
conseillère d'être conseillère de Paris
et ministre de la Culture pour vous oui
ça je pense que c'est tout à fait
compatible ce qui aurait été difficile
c'était d'être présidente de groupe
c'est évident alors justement c'est vous
qui es devenu présidente de groupe à sa
place 51 voix vous avez été élu avec 40
voix sur 51 est-ce que les neuf voix
manquantes ce sont les très proches de
Rachid hadti pour vous écoutez j'ai pas
cherché à compter je trouve qu'être élu
après de 80 % des voix c'est pas mal
tout le monde n'a pas ça dans la vie
politique après mon sujet c'est surtout
pas de compter c'est tout l'inverse
c'est de rassembler tout ce petit monde
que je connais bien avec lequel j'ai
travaillé pendant 3 ans et demi j'ai été
première vice-présidente j'ai assuré le
la direction du groupe pour ainsi dire
au côté de Rachid adati donc mon souci
c'est au contraire de continuer le mieux
possible de continuer être le le groupe
le premier groupe d'opposition à Paris
de de faire en sorte de dire ce qui ne
va pas mais surtout de dire nos
propositions parce que on prépare
l'alternance et on y compte bien dans 2
ans mais est-ce que vous sentez encore
chez elle la volonté de garder la main
sur le groupe ou est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes totalement libre indépendante
je pense alors je suis totalement libre
j'ai été élu je suis présidente et je
elle nintervient pas du tout
c'està-dire de président de Group vous
sentez pas une volonté chez elle de
garder la main mise sur le groupe mais
je pense que c'est pas comme ça que ça
se pose je pense d'abord qu'elle est
très prise par un portefeuille qui est
un portefeuille très large où il y a
beaucoup à faire et qu'elle fera
sûrement très bien après moi je suis
présidente de plein exercice évidemment
qu'on aura l'occasion de travailler
ensemble voilà mais c'est pas du tout
comme ça que les les choses se passent
elles se passe bien et ce qui nous
importe encore une fois c'est de gagner
Paris justement est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
Rach Dati reste votre meilleure
candidate votre meilleure chance de
gagner Paris en 2026ouû bien sûr elle
était notre candidate il y a 15 jours ça
a pas changé euh là aujourd'hui ce qui a
changé c'est qu'elle est plus elle a été
exclue des républicains oui tout à fait
bah ça on mais elle peut quand même
rester votre candidate on en prend acte
pour gagner Paris il faudra rassembler
alors évidemment les républicains sont
hyper majoritaires dans ce groupe c'est
loin qu'on puisse dire il y a énormément
de républicains après on sait très bien
que pour s'adresser au parisiens il
faudra qu'on soit tous rassemblés et
bien avant qu'elle soit ministre on le
sa savait on en parlait donc on
rassemblera et mais rassembler jusqu'au
Catherine dum est-ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire que pour gagner Paris
il faut faire un accord avec la majorité
présidentielle forcément il y a un
moment où il faudrait tous ensemble par
rapport à une gauche qui elle est bien
rassemblée hein et qui est bien large
aussi jusqu'aux extrêmes donc évidemment
nous il faudra qu'on se rassemble on
verra au bon moment comment ça se passe
la vie politique est quelque chose qui
va très très vite de plus en plus où on
en sera dans 6 mois dans un an on verra
bien pour l'instant on travaille Éric
cutier est d'accord avec ça pour une
alliance qui va jusqu'à la majorité
présidti il a fait son rôle de de
président de parti on va avoir
l'occasion je vais le revoir très vite
d'ailleurs on va avoir l'occasion d'en
reparler on associera tous les élus du
Conseil de Paris je parle des miens
évidemment de changer Paris et on
trouvera les bonnes solutions ça veut
dire que vous aujourd'hui vous
n'envisagez pas d'être candidate au
municipal ah non merci on m'a déjà
proposé beaucoup de choses certains
d'ailleurs trouvent que j'en fais trop
j'essaie de le faire le mieux possible
mais pour moi ça va je n'ai jamais eu
cette ambition je suis au Sénat je suis
bien dans cette maison j'ai envie de
beaucoup y travailler aux Affaires
étrangères il y a beaucoup à faire aussi
sur les affaires du monde qui sont pas
non plus d'une grande tranquillité donc
voilà je veux aussi m'y consacrer est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas aussi obligé d'avoir
rachéti comme candidate parce que
personne d'autre aujourd'hui n'incarne
la droite parisienne mieux qu'elle mais
on n'est pas obligé on a envie c'était
elle qui était prévu c'est toujours elle
c'est elle qui peut le mieux l'incarner
aujourd'hui c'est tout on va parler de
ce qui se passe à Paris et et notamment
cette votation qui a eu lieu dimanche
les Parisiens qui ont voté à 55 % pour
le triplement du stationnement des SUV à
Paris sauf qu'il y a eu moins de 6 % de
participation donc en fait ça fait à peu
près 3 % des Parisiens qui sont
favorables est-ce que ce vote a une
légitimité est-ce que annidalgo a raison
de mettre en place cette mesure à partir
du 1er septembre alors vous avez raison
3 % c'est quand même ça pose quelques
questions ça montre déjà que les
Parisiens sont pas trop intéressés à
cette votation alors sur le fond je
dirais d'abord première chose
quelque chose comme malheureusement tout
ce que fait la Gauche à Paris enfin en
tout cas très souvent très très mal
organisé d'abord on sait même pas quelle
est la question on nous fait une
communication sur une question qui est
êtes-vous pour ou contre les suuv plutôt
à l'échange je dirais et après on nous
pose une question qui n'a rien à voir
les Parisiens ont pas tout compris donc
déjà un défaut après l'organisation du
vote lui-même pose beaucoup de question
donc sur le fond déjà un vrai sujet
après sur la forme pardon sur le fond
sur le fond aussi sur le fond on une
fois de plus d'abord on oppose les
Parisiens les uns aux autres on nous dit
que et il s'agit donc de tripler le
montant du stationnement en fait on
s'aperçoit que les Parisiens eux-mêmes
la plupart seront exonérés de cette
mesure puisqu'ils sont ils bénéficient
d'un tarif résidentiel le stationnement
résidentiel n'est pas coné voilà que bon
les professionnels également
heureusement en fait ça s'adresse
beaucoup aux banlieusard qui eux même
ont un certain nombre de SUV mais pas
tant que ça donc on se rend compte que
ça va intéresser finalement très très
peu de personnes donc déjà moi j'ai
envie de dire tout ça pour ça beaucoup
de bruit pour pas grand-chose mais
est-ce qu'il faut renoncer à est-ce
qu'il faut renoncer à la mettre en place
oui et puis ce que je voudrais quand
même ajouter c'est qu'il y a quand même
une contradiction terrible par rapport
au débat écologique c'est qu'en fait les
voitures qui ont font leur transition
énergétique enfin les les Parisiens et
les Fran frilien qui ont entrepris
seront quand même taxés donc là il y a
une sacrée contradiction par rapport au
messagees écologiqu qu'on veut porter
donc est-ce qu'il faut le faire moi je
pense qu'on s'y prend très mal déjà si
nous sommes au pouvoir à Paris dans 2
ans on réfléchira à un système très
organisé de consultation des parisiens
mais qui permettra vraiment d'associer
tous les parisiens et puis sur le fond
encore une fois j'ai peur que ça soit
une mesurette qui fait beaucoup de bruit
pour peut-être détourner l'attention des
vrais problèmes parisiens ça veut dire
qu'anine dalgo elle a fait quoi une
consultation électoraliste pour faire
oublier certaines choses oui ça veut
dire qu'elle préfère qu'on parle de ça
et d'ailleurs elle nous a dit tout le
monde en a parlé B voilà donc c'était ça
le but elle elle a encore envie d'être
maire de Paris en 2026 selon vous malgré
quelques déclarations contraire il y a
encore quelques mois moi je trouve
qu'elle fait preuve d'une grande
pugnacité et de oui et qu'elle est
présente dans le débat politique elle
est pas forcément ment présente dans à
son fauteuil de mère pendant les 4 jours
du Conseil de Paris loin de là mais
qu'en revanche elle VI pas elle vient
pas au Conseil de Paris ouis elle est
très peu présente
physiquement mais en revanche je pense
donc y a quelques ce que vous dites
c'est qu'il y a quelques défaillances
dans sa manière d'exercer la gestion de
la ville bien sûr mais on l'a toujours
dit hein on l'a toujours dit mais malgré
ça est-ce que vous souhaitez que ce soit
elle la candidate de la moi je souhaite
rien du tout moi ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'on puisse avoir une alternance
de gouvernance à Paris un dernier mot
sur une autre actualité concerne Paris
c'est le président du PSG hier Nasser Al
rifi qui a annoncé que le club de la
capitale allait quitter le Parc des
Princes c'est fini maintenant on veut
bouger du parc des prince est-ce que
annidalgo a mal géré ce dossier a mal
géré les discussions avec le PSG alors
d'abord le Parc des Princes c'est pas
nimporte quoi c'est le plus beau stade
de la capitale c'est emblématique c'est
un symbole c'est au-delà de de du lieu
géographique avec ce club et c'est pas
dissociable donc c'est c'est très
important pour notre fierté de parisien
c'est un dossier qui encore une fois a
été géré alors tout à fait sans nous
l'opposition mais ça bon on a l'habitude
euh elle a fait des allerretour la mer
de Paris a a pris des positions est
revenu sur ses positions et là tout d'un
coup on s'aperçoit qu'elle elle dit
qu'elle ne veut pas vendre le Stan elle
dit aussi qu'elle a pas envie que le PSG
parte parce qu'elle se rend compte que
ça pose beaucoup de problèmes mais après
euh c'est à elle à négocier avec les
acteurs concernés pour trouver la bonne
solution moi tout ce que je dis c'est
que si le PSG partait c'est une
catastrophe et puis qu'est-ce qu'on fera
de ce stade vide donc c'est même pas
envisageable donc il faut trouver une
solution après attention attention je
pense que elle a été très loin que le
dialogue est quasiment rompu avec le le
le l'acteur principal oui et donc
attention de ne pas aller trop loin
parce qu'on risque d'aller à la
catastrophe merci Catherine Juma merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure